[Music]  doctor strange i always suspected this  day would come  because you always suspected this day  would come i'm ready  on may 6th  nothing can prepare you  for the mind-bending  descent into madness this is the only  way  doctors drink to the multiverse of  madness pg-13 seed in premium large  formats in imax  this universe  who is you  in this vast multiverse  stevens range your reckoning is long  overdue  [Music]  only beaters may 6th tickets on sale now  i've been  dreaming  every night  the same  nightmare  stranger  the fate of the multiverse  depends on us  careful stevens  [Music]  marvel studios doctor strange in the  multiverse of madness holding peters may  6th as it gets on sale now  [Music]  you